[Música]
el año pasado la nasa se fue una gran
pérdida perdió a su robot opportunity
durante junio de 2018 hubo una gran
tormenta de arena y polvo en el planeta
marte esta tormenta básicamente cubría
todo el planeta en una fina capa de
polvo y también oscureció los cielos
cuatro meses que duró esta tormenta
fueron demasiado tiempo para el robot
opportunity
el robot opportunity utilizaba paneles
solares para generar electricidad cargar
sus baterías y eventualmente activar
unos calentadores que lo ayudaban a
sobrevivir las frías noches en marcha
con esta tormenta los paneles solares se
cubrieron de polvo las baterías no se
pudieron cargar y eventualmente el robot
empezó a morir de frío lentamente
durante los 4 meses quedaron la tormenta
la nasa trato de mandarle más de 1000
comandos a este robot para tratar de
comunicarse con él y para tratar de
revivirlo durante estos 4 meses el robot
nunca respondió
el mes pasado en febrero del 2019 la
nasa dio oficialmente por terminada esta
misión se acabó opportunity opportunity
fue un gran éxito fue un robot que
rompió el récord de longevidad en otro
planeta dura más de 14 años activamente
explorando el planeta marte durante
estos 14 años exploró más de 45
kilómetros el martes lo que equivale más
a un poquito más de un maratón recorrido
en estos 14 años y nos regreso 200 mil
fotografías a nosotros
para que la nasa mando a este rover a
matt y para nacer para que los humanos
estamos mandando robert san martín pues
bueno son dos razones principales la
primera de ellas es el tratar de
contestar la pregunta de si estamos
solos los humanos siempre nos hemos
preguntado esto y pues bueno la mejor
manera de responder esta pregunta es
tratar de buscar vida en el planeta que
más se parece a la tierra en este caso
es martín
de hecho opportunity fue el primer robot
que descubrió indicios de piedras
sedimentarias el martes esto suena muy
aburrido pero es extremadamente
importante porque lo es muy bueno aquí
en la tierra sabemos que estas piedras
sedimentarias se forman en los lagos y
océanos cuando los ríos depositan
sedimento este segmento se va
compactando durante miles y miles de
años y forma un tipo muy especial de
piedra oportunity al descubrir este tipo
de piedras en marte lo que nos dice es
que en marte en algún punto de su
historia hubo grandes ríos lagos y
océanos y aquí en la tierra sabemos
dónde hay agua hay vida entonces está
punta todavía que marte puede ser un
posible planeta donde la vida haya
empezado la segunda razón es un poquito
más práctica y es que este robot va a
marte a explorar de una manera más
general en unos cuantos años tal vez de
queda se espera que los primeros humanos
puedan tocar marte para que esto suceda
lo que tenemos que hacer es estudiar el
planeta de una manera muy general hay
oxígeno en la atmósfera podemos sembrar
semillas en la tierra de marte podemos
minar hierro de marte todas estas
preguntas nos resuelven estos roberts al
explorar el planeta y ver de qué está
hecho y bueno esto prepara
a los humanos para poder colonizar marte
este evento la colonización de marte
sería un parteaguas en la historia de
toda la humanidad nuestra civilización
se volvería una civilización
interplanetaria y una vez que una
civilización se vuelve interplanetaria
ya no hay vuelta atrás después de marte
unos cuantos años después podríamos
empezar a colonizar lunas del sistema
solar y mucho mucho tiempo después
podríamos también colonizar planetas de
esta galaxia este evento para nosotros
no será muy futurístico y tal vez no nos
importe mucho pero para sus tatara
tatara tatara nietos va a ser un evento
mucho mucho mucho más importante que el
descubrimiento de américa el volvernos
interplanetarios y entonces son las dos
razones buscar vida y prepararnos para
colonizar marte por la que mandamos
estos roberts con estas dos razones tan
nobles podríamos imaginarnos que la nada
se ha mandado muchísimo de estos robots
a marte pero no es el caso en sus más de
60 años de historia la nada solamente ha
mandado cuatro robots
y por qué es esto pues bueno podríamos
pensar que el costo verdad opportunity
costó 400 millones de dólares no es
mucho dinero pero por ejemplo para eeuu
son unos cuantos centavitos entonces el
costo no es realmente la razón por la
que hemos ganado tan poquitos robots la
razón principal es la dificultad técnica
como ustedes se pueden imaginar manda un
tipo de estos robots a marte es
extremadamente difícil y porque es
difícil pues bueno tenemos el
lanzamiento o graxal en nuestro cohete
de la tierra cargando nuestro robot esta
etapa no es muy difícil y luego tenemos
el viaje que dura seis meses desde la
tierra hasta marte pero tampoco es muy
difícil y ahora sí viene la parte más
difícil de este viaje el aterrizaje en
marte y porque es difícil porque cuando
nuestra cápsula espacial que trae a este
robot adentro ya está viendo a marte en
su ventana ya está cerca ya está listo
para aterrizar la nave espacial está
viajando a 18.000 kilómetros por hora 5
kilómetros cada segundo o 5 veces más
rápido que una bala entonces el problema
aquí es como nos vamos a frenar como nos
vamos a desacelerar de estos 18.000
kilómetros por hora hasta cero verdad
porque si el robot aterriza con 10
kilómetros por hora
todos tenemos que desear hasta 0 km por
hora y esto lo tenemos que hacer en
siete minutos estos siete minutos de más
o menos lo que se tarda el robot desde
que choca con la atmósfera de marte
hasta que llega a la superficie
y para hacer todo esto más complicado
aún lo tenemos que hacer mientras
nuestra nave espacial está a 55 millones
de kilómetros mucho muy lejos de la
tierra
y bueno para ver cómo esta etapa se
realiza como los ingenios de la nasa de
resolver este problema vamos a ver como
opportunity aterrizó en marte en 2004
sale el cohete de la tierra este
encuentro trae a nuestro robot y
eventualmente dieciséis o siete meses
después llega a marte bueno ya está
listo para llegar a marte y aquí es
cuando nuestra nave espacial está
viajando a 18.000 kilómetros por hora y
es donde la parte difícil empieza como
estamos viajando tan tan rápido lo
primero que va a pasar es que nuestra
cápsula espacial choca con la atmósfera
instantáneamente se convierte en un
meteorito todo esté en la velocidad que
trae genera un calor enorme y
básicamente crea una bola de fuego un
escudo térmico en esta nave espacial nos
protege de este calor tan inmenso y
nuestro robot se sigue de largo
eventualmente dejamos de ser un
meteorito nos frenamos lo suficiente y
activamos unos paracaídas como la
atmósfera de marte es tan tenue para que
ellas no lo pueden frenar de todos y
solamente utilizamos paracaídas extrae
estrellar y amos al robot con 400
kilómetros por hora en la superficie de
marte y entonces los sitios de la nada
se en 2004 para poder aterrizar a
opportunity lo que decidieron hacer es
esta la cápsula se abre la cápsula y
sale una especie de bolsa y se inflan
bolsas de aire alrededor del robot
empieza a votar como portes 10 minutos
en la superficie de marte con cada bote
absorbemos esta energía esta que
llevamos es 18 mil kilómetros por hora y
eventualmente nos detenemos
y toda esta secuencia se tiene que hacer
de forma automática por la computadora
como las señales de radio que mandamos
de aquí en la tierra marte como estamos
a 55 millones de kilómetros estar más o
menos 14 minutos en llegar pues de nada
nos sirve tener aquí en la tierra un
monto que diga abrir paracaídas si esa
señal se va a tardar 14 minutos en
llegar y toda la secuencia de aterrizaje
dura más o menos 7 minutos y de hecho
por este tiempo este tipo de tiempos se
conoce a esta secuencia de aterrizaje
como los 7 minutos del terror porque
cuando el robot está chocando con la
atmósfera está haciendo un meteorito nos
mandó una señal de radio esa señal de
radio se matará en 14 minutos en llegar
con nosotros pero el robot sigue de
largo porque él sigue con su aterrizaje
y cuando sigue de largo eso es dura 7
minutos pues para cuando nosotros
recibimos esa señal de radio que el
robot está haciendo un meteorito está
empezando su aterrizaje nosotros
realmente estamos que es una señal
desfasada y por lo tanto el robot ya
lleva 7 minutos en la superficie ya
acabó su aterrizaje pero todavía no
sabemos si ese robot lo hizo de forma
exitosa o se estrelló
estos son 7 minutos de incertidumbre en
que tenemos que esperar esta señal
radio que vienen desplazadas a que
lleguen a nosotros
y por eso se le conoce a esta secuencia
como los siete minutos del terror son
muchos nervios y bueno esta secuencia
tan loca no ha pasado solamente una vez
de hecho ha pasado tres veces en la
historia la primera de ellas en 1997 con
el robot path finder que es el primer
robot que aterrizó en marte en 1997 y
otras dos veces pasó en 2004 una de
ellas fue por tu mente y como ya
platiqué y la segunda ya fue el gemelo
de opportunity que era un robot que se
llamaba spirit pathfinder es el robot
pequeñito tenemos spirit que es un robot
mediano del tamaño de un carrito de golf
y esos dos aterrizado en 2004 el robot
que será aquí más grande se llama
curiosity que es el robot más reciente
de la nasa y aterrizó en marte en 2000
julio cities son robots mucho más capaz
y por ejemplo tiene una batería nuclear
en lugar de utilizar paneles solares
entonces cuando esta tormenta de arena
mató aporte un tipo que se quedó sin
batería
curiosity no le importó porque él tenía
una batería nuclear que no importaba el
sol y éste curiosity es el único robot
que sigue explorando mart es el único
que nos queda este robot como pueden ver
pues es un robot mucho más grande
estamos hablando de una tonelada
del tamaño de un mini cooper un robot
mucho mucho más capaz y como es tan
pesado este robot no pudo aterrizar en
marte con el mismo sistema de bolsas de
aire que los otros robots entonces en
2012 los ingenios de la nasa tuvieron
que diseñar otro sistema de aterrizaje
la primera parte nuestra cápsula
espacial chocamos a 18.000 kilómetros
por hora 2 con la atmósfera y nos
convertimos en un meteorito entonces nos
empezamos a frenar los juego térmico nos
protege de este infierno tan tan
caluroso y eventualmente podemos
disparar nuestros paracaídas recordemos
que los paracaídas no nos van a poder
afinar el todo porque la atmósfera de
marte es muy tenue si solamente
utilizáramos paracaídas el robot se
estrellara en la superficie con 300 o
400 kilómetros por hora esto descubrió a
600 2012 lo que tuvo que hacer es una
vez que los paga que es lo frenaron lo
suficiente se digamos se destapa de esa
cápsula espacial que lo lleva protegido
activo unos cohetes y empieza a bajar
lentamente en un sistema de grúa hacia
la superficie de marte
va bajando lentamente cada vez creándose
un poquito un poquito más los cohetes
que están echando fuego y humo no pueden
chocar con la superficie de marte porque
podrían dañar al robot oa las piedras y
polvo que mueve entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es bajar al robot en un
sistema de cables ya tenemos este
sistema de péndulo con grúa y todo muy
bien cuidadosamente va bajando se la
superficie de marte
todo muy lentamente muy bien controlado
cuidadosamente eventualmente las llantas
del robot chocan o tocan la superficie
de marte y en ese momento sabemos que
aterrizamos satisfactoriamente mandamos
señales cortamos los cables y termina la
munición de la turba con cuentas que se
vais a estrella a unos cuantos
kilómetros de distancia
y es así como curiosity aterrizó en
marte en 2012
esta secuencia realmente pasó en 2012 y
va a pasar otra vez en 2020 todas estas
secuencias se tienen que hacer de forma
automática por la computadora porque de
nuevo las señales de radio aunque van
viajando la velocidad de la luz que
estará en 14 minutos sin llegar a la
tierra entonces toda la computadora
tiene que saber exactamente lo que está
haciendo y resolver cualquier problema
que podría pasar
de la misma forma que oportuno y tierra
que ya está muerto tenía un gemelo
curiosa y tiene un robot que su hermano
pequeño que está a punto de dejar el
nido y este robot es marte 2020 que es
el nuevo rover de la nasa este robot es
un clon más o menos es el hermano de
curiosos y se parece mucho tiene el
mismo tamaño casi pesa lo mismo y es que
los robots ya nos podemos ser más
grandes porque los cohetes de la tierra
apoyándonos dando estamos dando los
cohetes más poderosos que tenemos y por
lo tanto el robo ya no puede ser más
grande
marte 2020 va a aterrizar el martes en
el verano de 2020 y va a utilizar este
mismo sistema de grúa con cohetes para
aterrizar entonces si se ponen a ver la
noticias eso va realmente va a pasar en
el verano de 2020 este robot tiene dos
novedades la primera de ellas es un
nuevo sistema de recolección de muestras
en la mano del robot va haber un taladro
este taladro va a taladrar piedras el
martes iba a sacar boquetes de piedra
más o no del tamaño de un dedo y las va
a poner en la panza del robot la panza
del robot hay otro sistema robótico que
agarra esa muestra la pone en un tubo
metálico y se sella herméticamente como
una lata vamos a enlatar piedras
el robot va a ir a marte a enlatar 37 de
estas piedras y después de que en la
tendrán siete de estas piedras él va a
depositar en la superficie
porque la nasa está gastando dos
billones de dólares para mandar un robot
a marte de aterrizar de esa forma tan
complicada para enlatar 37 piedras y
dejarlas en la superficie pues bueno se
espera que en unos años otros robots de
la nasa llegue a marte aterricé
recolecta esas muestras que ya están
selladas herméticamente la ponga de
regreso en un pequeño cohete y ese
cohete salga de marte y empiece a
orbitar marte de la forma que nuestros
satélites orbitan a la tierra después
otro cohete sale de la tierra llega a
marte intercepta ese satélite que está
orbitando marte y se trae esas muestras
esas latas con piedras hasta la tierra
esta secuencia tan complicada es la
única forma de traer muestras de marte
con nosotros y esto porque es importante
pues bueno si recordamos las razones por
qué estamos mandando roberts
estamos tratando encontrar vida y tal
vez es más fácil traer un pedacito de
marte con nosotros que mandar robots con
máquinas que están compactas y ahora
todo lo que dan hacia marte estas
muestras cuando una vez las tengamos en
nuestra posesión las podemos estudiar
por cientos de años y tal vez con las
máquinas tan precisas que tenemos aquí
en la tierra realmente podremos
encontrar indicios de vida
sería el descubriendo científico más
importante de toda la historia mi rol en
este proyecto es el de probar este
sistema de recolección de muestras para
asegurarnos que halle la perfección
antes de mandarla martes llevamos dos
años probando la la segunda novedad de
este de esta misión marte 2020 es la
adición de un helicóptero en la panza
del robot va a ver un pequeño drone que
va a estar protegido con una coraza
mientras los 7 minutos del terror pasa
aterriza el robot y deposita el
helicóptero
el helicóptero va a empezar a volar en
marte y va a tomar fotografías del
entorno del robot para ayudarle a los
pilotos que mueven al robot a manejarlo
de una forma más eficiente
este helicóptero es realmente una
maravilla tecnológica y es que volar en
marte es extremadamente difícil de la
misma forma que los paracaídas del
aterrizaje no tienen suficiente aire
donde agarrarse pues las aspas del
helicóptero tampoco tiene mucho aire y
no crean mucho empuje entonces el
helicóptero pesa 2 kilos las aspas de un
metro de diámetro y tienen que girar
extremadamente rápido para poder volar
en el aire tanto de martín
miren este en este proyecto es diseñar
un sistema que simula la gravedad de
marte que es el 30 por ciento de fuerte
que la de la tierra pues en marte las
cosas pesan menos y tenemos que simular
ese efecto aquí en la tierra para poder
asegurarnos que este helicóptero
funcione a la perfección antes de
mandarla a marte
y bueno pues con esta nueva misión
estamos comentando helicópteros a marte
y ya estamos en el futuro para quien se
hubiera imaginado que íbamos a tener
helicópteros a marte
ya para terminar los quiero dejar con la
siguiente fotografía
este es un anochecer o un atardecer el
mar que los colores no son tan bonitos
ya que la atmósfera de marte se tienen
con una composición diferente y sale
unos colores rosáceos pero aquí quiero
que se fije en el puntito blanco que se
ve ahí en esa estrella que realmente no
es una estrella esa es el planeta tierra
donde tú y yo vivimos vistos desde mar
es una foto que tomó curiosity de un
anochecer el martes donde nos vemos
todos nosotros ahí donde todos nosotros
vivimos y bueno esperemos que con toda
la información que estos robots han
recopilado a lo largo de la historia
estas fotografías no solamente sean
tomadas por robots sino por los primeros
humanos que puedan tocar marte gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]